welcome back to the world of competitive
Pokemon the last video was all about
stats so now it's time to battle like I
said last time I'll be focusing on the
official competitive format called the
VTC which means we'll be talking about
double battles there are quite a few
moves abilities items and general
strategies to consider in double battles
that you rarely use in singles there's a
lot of depth to what you can do with 4
Pokemon on the field at once which is
why I find doubles so exciting
competitive Pokemon is about planning
and executing your own strategy while
predicting and disrupting your
opponent's the more you battle the more
you'll be able to look at a team in team
preview and get an idea of what your
opponent's strategy might be the goal of
this video is to give you the foundation
you need to be able to learn something
with every battle win or lose so these
are the big picture strategies you need
to know about
[Music]
and didn't talk about abilities in the
stat video so in short every Pokemon has
one ability and each species of Pokemon
can have between one and three abilities
most of which have some kind of effect
in battle for example my competitive
drag a poll from the last video has the
ability clear body while the
non-competitive one has infiltrator
instead a lot of popular strategies and
corporate abilities in some way or
another
so I'll be talking about different
abilities and their effects throughout
the video but to start I do have to talk
about stats just a little bit more
[Applause]
last time I said that understanding
stats will help you understand
everything else about competitive
Pokemon that's partially because
manipulating Pokemon stats in battle is
a major overall strategy with a lot of
layers you can lower opposing Pokemon
stats increase the stats of your own
Pokemon and generally mess with stats
during a battle using abilities moves
weather and items this will get more
exciting in a second I promise but first
some jargon raising or lowering a stat
in battle comes in what's called stages
you'll get texts like Charizard special
attack fell or swine up special defense
rose sharply to indicate the change if
it just says rose or fell that means the
stat was changed by one stage while if
it says rose sharply or harshly fell
that means the stat was changed by two
stages you can change a stat by six
stages in either direction and
everything goes back to zero when a
Pokemon switches out of the battle you
can track what stage each Pokemon is in
for every stat by pressing Y during a
battle for those who are interested in
the math each stage above zero
represents 50% increments so if a move
raises a Pokemon special defense stat by
two stages that means that special
defense has been doubled from its
starting value and you'll see that
referred to as +2 special defense at
minus two a stat is reduced to half of
its original value but the drops after
that gets smaller and smaller and cap
out at 1/4 of the original value at
stage negative six moves like haze and
clear smog can reset stat stages and
because switching out also has that
effect you can use moves like dragon
tail and roar to force your opponent's
out if they're trying to set up a
boosted onslaught you'll see stat stages
and changes in tons of strategies so
that brings us to speed control
it probably goes without saying but
moving first in a battle is usually
preferable there are a number of ways to
manipulate speed on the field and most
VGC teams will have one or more of them
you're likely used to the idea that
faster pokemon move first in a battle
but turn order is actually more
dependent on a hidden factor called
priority all moves are sorted into a
priority bracket that looks like this
turn order is determined first by what
priority bracket the move is in then by
each Pokemon speed stat so if one
pokemon on the field uses helping hand
that will always go first because it's
the highest priority move but if two
pokemon use helping hand in the same
turn the faster one will use it first
you can use priority to your advantage
by using a move like quick attack to
knock out a week into Pokemon before it
can attack you for example for non
damaging support moves the ability
prankster is especially popular because
it increases all status moves by one
priority bracket on that note one of the
most common methods of speed control is
the move tailwind which increases speed
on your side of the field by two stages
and lasts four turns whimsicott is
largely considered the best tailwind
center thanks to the prankster ability
it can set up tailwind before other
faster Pokemon have a chance to move he
could speed and turn order or
recalculated as changes happen this
means whimsicott sparked 'nor can also
out speed those Pokemon right away if
you see a whimsicott in team preview you
can bet that it knows tailwind
alternatively you can also dynamics a
pokemon that knows a flying-type move to
get max air stream which increases the
speed of both of your Pokemon by one
stage and does a good amount of damage
on top of that this only applies to the
Pokemon currently out on the field when
you use it though while tailwind applies
to all your Pokemon as long as it's
active you can also just paralyze your
opponent to cut it speed stat in half
grim snarl with the prankster ability
can use Thunder Wave to paralyze fast
opponents like drag a pullet before they
can move for example by the way if
you're worried about prankster pokemons
setting up these strategies or any
others before you can even move you
can't ride the move fake out which only
works on the first turn of Pokemon is in
battle but causes the target to flinch
and waste its turn fake out has a higher
priority than every prankster boosted
status move that whimsicott and grim
snarl can learn you can fake them out
and then ko them with a powerful Pokemon
before they can gain any momentum
dark-type pokémon are also immune to
prankster boosted moves which is handy
lastly there's the move trick room which
reverses turn
within each priority bracket that means
helping hand will still go first but if
two Pokemon use it the slower one will
use it first instead trick room itself
has the lowest priority of any move and
although it lasts for five turns the
first turn you use it counts so
essentially you have four turns at a
time to let your slower pokemon shine
for hard trick room teams players will
often breed their pokemon with a speed
IV of zero and nature's that hinder
speed to help ensure their Pokemon are
as slow as possible common trick room
users include Gotha tell dusclops
catarina and mini q and strong trick
room pokemon include rhyperior torkoal
and Conkeldurr though all you really
need to be sure of is that your Pokemon
are slower than your opponents and mixed
or more flexible trick room teams are
also worth trying
some Pokemon are just really strong
attackers and that is often very scary
fully offensive Pokemon want to be in a
position where they can sweep your team
with ease so your job is to not let that
happen intimidate is an incredibly
important ability for this it activates
whenever the Pokemon with intimidate is
sent into battle and lowers both
opponents attack by one stage you can
also burn a physical attacker which will
reduce its attack by 50% just beware of
Pokemon with the abilities defiant or
competitive which rays attack or special
attack respectively by two stages when
the Pokemon steps are lowered players
will use teammates like brave iary or
melodic to discourage intimidates if the
opponent is a special attacker instead
you can use the move snarl to lower both
opponents special attack by one stage
Arcanine can have intimidate and learn
snarl and on top of that it can also
learn will-o-wisp which burns the target
I really like using arcanine as a
support pokemon since it's so versatile
so long as I can be sure the intimidate
won't screw me over also a lot of really
strong Pokemon will have lower speed so
preventing trick room or countering it
with your own trick room can save you as
can preventing other forms of speed
control like tailwind offensive Pokemon
are usually not as defensive too so you
can counter them with your own
hard-hitting Pokemon just make sure you
check whether the Pokemon is more
physically defensive or especially
defensive you'll have a much easier time
taking down Snorlax with physical
attacks for example
[Music]
this is a quick one but it's important
to know about some moves and abilities
can redirect moves away from the
intended target
a big one is Follow Me which you'll
often see on Togekiss and female indeedy
even if you targeted the other Pokemon
the move will hit the follow me user the
move rage powder which you might see on
Butterfree works the same way the
ability lightning rod will redirect an
electric-type attack and boost the
Pokemon special attack while storm drain
does the same for water type moves and
the move alloys switch will cause to
partner Pokemon to change places which
means that a move targeting one Pokemon
will end up hitting the other Doral
Adhan stalwart ability ignores all
redirection moves to hit the intended
target so it's a powerful counter to
these strategies you can also get around
it by using a spread move like hyper
voice or rockslide to hit both opponents
at once
one of the best moves in the VGC is
protect pretty much every pokemon can
learn it and it's a valuable tool in
lots of different situations you can
protect to stall like when you're
waiting for trick room to expire or if
you think your opponent might double
target one of your pokemon with both of
theirs leaving your other Pokemon open
to attack there are variations on
protect - including a handy move called
wide guard that protects a team from
spread moves specifically switching your
Pokemon out of battle is also a viable
strategy you can switch an intimidate
user out so they can live to intimidate
later on for example or switch to a
Pokemon that resists attacks you're
anticipating to put yourself in a better
position for the next turn the ability
shadow tag which you'll see on Gotha
tell prevents opponents from switching
out but ghost types are immune
every competitive Pokemon needs a held
item and while there's a lot of held
items out there these are some of the
ones you'll see most often the focus
sash prevents the pokemon from being
knocked out in one hit from full HP
you'll see this on fragile pokémon like
whimsicott Katarina and Schindler who
have to survive at least one turn to do
their main job there's a variety of
berries your Pokemon can eat during a
battle pinch berries will activate when
your pokemons HP gets low and healed
them while another class of rare berries
will reduce the damage taken from one
super effective move Togekiss for
example will often hold up a berry berry
which helps that survive one skill type
attack when a Pokemon holding weakness
policy is hit by a super effective move
its attack and special attack go up by
two stages offensive Pokemon that can
survive at least one hit like rhyperior
a load on and offensive Togekiss sets
will frequently have this and you can
even attack your own weakness policy
Pokemon to trigger it there are three
choice items each of which boosts a stat
by 50% but locks the holder into the
first movement used in the battle choice
band increases attack choice specs
increases special attack and choice
scarf increases speed the move you're
locked into will reset when you switch
out of battle or while your Dynomax life
orb increases the power of the holders
attacks but each time it uses a damaging
move it loses a bit of HP the flame orb
burns its holder after a turn this is
actually good for Pokemon with the
ability guts which increases their
attack stat when they have a status
condition if you're worried about an
opponent's item making your life hard
you can use the move knockoff to get rid
of it or the moves trick and switcheroo
which will switch your held item with
the targets weather is a long-standing
strategy and competitive pokemon and
you'll see weather changes in lots of
battles because weather strategies
incorporate everything from speed
control and abilities to attack power
and defensive maneuvers the idea is to
set up weather to give your team an
advantage you can change the weather
using moves like sunny day or rain dance
but one strategy is to include a Pokemon
on your team with an ability that
triggers weather instead if two Pokemon
with weather setting abilities come out
on the field at the same time the faster
ones weather will be overwritten by the
slower ones which will trigger a second
take Tyranitar for example with the
ability sand stream
can set up a sandstorm for five turns
and because sandstorms increase the
special defense of rock-type pokémon by
50%
this helps Tyranitar take hits from
powerful special attackers but Tyranitar
is faster than torkoal which is usually
bred to have minimum speed for trick
room and can set up harsh sunlight with
the drought ability so if your opponent
has a torkoal don't leave with Tyranitar
switch it in on turn one instead to
overwrite the weather and save yourself
from sun boosted fire type attacks this
will also help a partner like melodic
actually do damage and Sun reduces the
power of water type attacks by 50%
there's also abilities that can take
advantage of weather and you'll
frequently see duo's or even entire
teams based around a certain weather
condition excadrill can have the ability
sand rush which increases its speed in a
sandstorm players using this strategy
will try to lead with Tyranitar and
excadrill so excadrill can sweep with
it's boosted speed in the sandstorm and
then the rest of the team is usually
more balanced then there are full
weather teams where the whole team is
geared around the desired weather this
includes the sample rain team you can
rent from the battle tower if you're
curious and want to try it out on that
team pelipper is the rains that are
using the ability drizzle plus it can
learn tailwind three of the pokemon have
the ability Swift swim which increases
speed and rain rights use lightning rod
ability protects its partners from
electric type attacks by redirecting and
absorbing them and the normally low
accuracy Thunder hits consistently in
rain even Ferrothorn benefits because it
has a four times weakness to fire and
rain decreases the power of fire type
moves by 50%
you can also change the weather using
certain max moves which I'll get to in a
bit
[Music]
before we talk about diana maxing more I
have to mention terrain it's separate
from weather and affects only the
Pokemon on the ground so basically every
Pokemon except flying types and ones
with the ability levitate like weather
terrain can be triggered by some
abilities their corresponding moves or
certain max moves there are four types
electric misty grassy and psychic in
addition to affecting some move types
each one has an additional bonus that
can be really helpful Electric terrain
prevents sleep misty terrain prevents
burn paralysis poison freezing and sleep
as well as confusion psychic prevents
Pokemon from being hit by priority moves
and grassy heals all Pokemon on the
ground a bit each turn it's active
you'll often see in didi with the
ability psychic surge paired with hey
Doreen so how terrain can safely set up
trick room psychic terrain protects hot
iron from fake out and indeed ease
follow me then helps prevent it from
getting Kayode
finally let's talk about Dyna maxing
it's definitely an intimidating mechanic
that almost seems opiate first but when
you break it down there are basically
three reasons you'd want a Dynomax the
first is to do big damage max moves are
super powerful and in the hands of a
strong attacker like Durant they can
one-hit ko Pokemon if your opponent
isn't prepared the second is to trigger
stat changes whether or Terrain max worm
wind reduces your opponent's attack
while max Starfall triggers misty Tyrion
for example and the third is to increase
your overall bulkiness Dynomax thing is
the only thing that can increase your
total HP in a battle and it can make
defensive pokémon like melodic even
harder to take down at a pinch you can
do all of these things at once - Durant
is an incredible Dynomax candidate
because of its sheer power and speed and
also its move pool this one knows steel
rock and ground type moves max rock fall
will trigger a sandstorm if needed while
max steel spike boosts your defense and
max quake boost special defense
this helps Durant lived through its
three Dynomax turns in tandem with the
HP boost although during special defense
is pretty bad so it's better to knock
out special attackers the stat boosts
also really helped Durant's partner as
the battle wears on by making it harder
to take down that's just one example of
a good Dynomax choice and it's
definitely a mechanic that will shift
over time the best way to really get a
sense of good Dynomax strategies and
battle strategies in general is to just
practice you'll see what other people
are doing and you'll figure out over
time what does and doesn't work about
the team's you use
[Music]
while battling online you will often
have the chance to view your opponent's
team after the battle which I highly
recommend this can expose you to items
abilities or moves you didn't know about
as well as the kinds of sets people run
on certain Pokemon I also really
recommend using rental teams made by
experienced players so you can start
battling right away getting experience
and then moving on to breeding which is
why breeding and training is the next
video you can find great rental teams on
Victory Road VGC and trainer tower
sometimes with full breakdowns and
explanations by the team's creator as
always please reach out to me in the
comments or on Twitter with any
questions stay tuned for the next video
all about breeding and training and
thanks for watching
[Music]